well so Jen I can tell you that's gonna
use understand I've had a second death
19 this is a man in his 8 in his 80s at
Milton Keynes General Hospital
who is believed to have died with the
virus we don't know more about his case
but it would be the second death during
this outbreak and obviously a matter of
huge concern around the world there have
now been 3,400 deaths
there's the latest figures and it just
shows how difficult this virus is going
to be and how threatening it will be for
7 groups it's important of course not to
be alarmist we were told to expect some
deaths and from cave-in 19 in the UK as
this outbreak grows and from what we've
learnt so far again as she said scant
details about the second case so far but
it does seem to be older people with
underlying health problems that are
really a risk for pay that 19 you're
absolutely right for younger individuals
and for those who are otherwise healthy
this virus does not seem to be a
significant concern but it is very
specific risk groups those who are
particularly over 60 and with increasing
age the risk also increases but also
people with certain underlying health
issues such as lung disease heart
disease hypertension and so on those are
the ones but even if they do get the
virus all the research shows that their
chance of surviving it nineteen ninety
five percent and that's based in China
the feeling is there here in the UK with
the excellent health care we have here
that the survival chances would be even
higher than that so one has to bear that
in mind
you